Just before we get started with today's video,
I do want to thank brilliance for making it possible to support biographics and
learn more about brilliant.
Go to brilliant.org/buyer graphics and sign up for free.
Okay.
His was the brain that oversaw the most destructive projects in all of human
history.
It's won a war by unleashing unimaginable horror in the process,
catapulting the world into the nuclear age for his efforts.
He was accused of being a Russian spy and sidelined by the government.
In this week's biographics graphics,
we're taking a look at the life and the work of j Robert Oppenheimer Junius.
Robert Oppenheimer was born on April the 20 seconds 1904 in New York City.
His father Julius had fled Jewish persecution in Europe as a teenager.
His mother Ballo was also Jewish with that family,
having been a New York for several generations,
the couple were married in 1903 with Julius.
He was known as Robert the end of their first child.
A second son,
frank came along in 1912 when Robert was eight years old.
The family lived in an upscale apartments on New York's west side.
Julius had built a successful textile importing business and and there was a
painter they employed to cook sevenths and to show fat.
Life for young Robert was structured and formal with dinner as requiring a suit
and tie.
Okay.
When Robert was five years old,
the family took a vacation to Germany.
There he met his grandfather who gave him a collection of minerals.
He was mesmerized by the stones needing to a lifelong obsession with rock
collecting.
When he was 11 he joins the New York mineralogical club.
A year later,
he presented his first scientific paper.
Julia sent his son to the best school he could find the New York school for
ethical culture.
Robert attended from the second grade right through to college graduation.
The focus of the education was science,
literature and moral law.
Robert was an eight grade students who completely devoted himself to his
studies.
As a result,
he doesn't have much of a social life friends.
They were few and far between.
In fact,
according to his high school English teacher,
he once said,
I'm the loneliest man in the world.
Robert was extremely socially awkward as a teenager.
From the start,
he considered himself the smartest guy in the room and this led to an arrogance
which was off putting to as peers.
They were also so put off by his prim and proper nature.
Yeah.
After graduating from high school,
he attended Harvard in order to pursue a serious scientific studies.
He majored in chemistry,
but soon fell in love with physics.
He was admitted into graduate studies in physics and began studying under the
famous experimentalists,
Percy Bridgman,
all the the knew straight away that this was what he wanted to do with his life.
He took a rigorous course load each semester,
which allowed him to graduate in just three years.
At that time,
the American college's couldn't compete with the physics laboratories.
Europe,
the science world was enthralled with the physics revelations of Albert Einstein
and for any,
it's serious up and coming.
American physicist crossing the Atlantic was an essential requirements.
In 1924 Oppenheimer was admitted to Kevin dish laboratory and Cambridge England.
This was one of the most renowned and nuclear physics labs in the world.
The lab was under the direction of Ernest Rutherford who had already won the
Nobel prize for splitting the atom.
Oppenheimer was assigned to a team of researchers under the leadership of Jj
Thomson,
who in 1897 had discovered the electron.
It was the ultimate setting for a budding physics genius,
but Oppenheimer quickly realized that it wasn't really cut out for it.
P and experimental physics that just didn't Gel.
He wasn't able to keep up with the required workloads and you want my suffered a
mental breakdown by now.
We had developed a habit as a chain smoker and it's often neglected basic
hygiene and nutritional practices as he got bogged down with his work,
but trying as he may,
he was unable to keep up with the required workload.
Hey,
depressed and overwhelmed up and I went to see a psychiatrist who told him that
he was suffering from schizophrenia.
The prognosis,
it was not good with longterm institutionalization being the standard treatment
at the time.
Oppenheimer refuse to believe this diagnosis.
He took a vacation to Paris with his friend Francis Ferguson.
However,
he wasn't exactly good company being consumed with his own melancholy Ferguson
drying to cheer him up by breaking the news that he was going to marry his
girlfriends.
When he heard this,
something inside Oppenheimer's fragile mind snapped and he leaped upon Ferguson
and proceeded to strangle him.
Ferguson was able to fend them off,
but from then on he became convinced that his friends had serious mental
problems.
Okay.
In 1926 off and nine it took up a position at the University of Gottingen in
Germany.
This was the sensor of theoretical physics in Europe and Oppenheimer landed
right in the middle of a revolution in the field.
He found himself rubbing shoulders with and learning from the premier names in
quantum physics,
including Enrico Fermi,
Wolfgang Pauli and Verner Heisenberg here.
Finally,
Oppenheimer found his perfect fit.
In 1927 he received his phd in physics.
Over the next two years,
he established himself as one of the leading physicists in Europe publishing 16
papers on quantum physics.
American physicist said,
been left behind by the European quantum physics revolution.
Many of the professors refuse to accept the new counselor.
Intuitive theories that went against the grain of everything they had known.
This left a slew of Iga physicists excited about what was happening in Europe
and left out in the cold open.
I'm a sore,
saw himself as the vehicle by which the European advances in quantum physics
could be introduced to American physicists.
His first position back in the state swells as a professor at the University of
California Berkeley.
He now has a,
had a brimming with knowledge and lecture halls filled with students,
see what you get to learn from him.
The problem was he didn't know how to teach his social awkwardness.
It certainly didn't tell me that he would become tongue tied in front of his
students.
When he did speak,
his ideas would come out as a jumbled mass of words.
That's simply served to confuse those in attendance.
By the end of his first semester,
that was just one student remaining who was taking his class for credit.
Fortunately though,
things got better.
He applied himself to his teaching and slowly improved his disability.
He managed to cut out the verbiage to pare down his lectures,
making them both understandable and exciting as a result of the students who
referred to him as puppy.
Again,
flocking to his lectures within a couple of years,
a cult of personality he had developed around him and he had his own groupies
who were known as ops Boyers.
He relished the attention and he gave his time generously to a students.
Often discussions would be hands off to class with students even ending up at
his home.
The subject usually more from physics to science to art and literature runs
would be fueled by generous quantities of alcohol.
While teaching at Berkeley Oppenheimer that continued his physics research,
the published more papers on quantum physics but did not make any groundbreaking
discoveries.
He did,
however,
convert the Berkeley lab into a world class facility,
establishing the new quantum physics as a legitimate science in America.
Often high mag totally immersed himself in his work and the agitation of his
students.
He did not own a phone or radio or even read the newspaper when his mind wasn't
on physics.
He would be studying Hindu mythology or the ancient classics.
As a result,
he was totally divorced from the outside world when the Great Depression struck
following the 1929 Wall Street crash,
he was simply none the wiser being NC United from the effects thanks to a trust
fund.
Now,
just before we get into Oppenheimer's work during the war,
let me take a quick break,
just tell you a bit about brilliance.
As always,
I know mid role ads in the middle here,
they're not perfect,
but when we started biographics,
we really wanted it to be a longer form content channel and well sponsors.
They make it possible.
Now you've heard me talk about brilliant before that we're learning platform
that focuses on active learning.
This is where you're given a short bit of information on the scientific concepts
and then you're asked to solve a problem based on that information.
It's an incredibly effective way to learn right now.
Brilliant.
Have something that would be perfect as a new year's resolution,
even if that new year's resolution is coming a little bit late.
It's called daily problems,
and it's five minutes a day that you can use to exercise your brain and learn
something new.
Each problem provides you the context and a framework that you need to tackle
it.
That means you can learn concepts by applying them.
That's that active learning.
Again,
this sort of short daily practice can lead you from curiosity to mastery and far
less time than you would like.
So go to brilliant.org forward slash biographics and finish your day a little
smarter.
And for the first 200 of you that do so,
you'll get 20% off the annual subscription and you can also view all of the
wrong ones from the archives.
So how's that again?
Brilliance.
Check them out.
All link in the description below.
Let's get back to Oppenheimer.
It was the effect that the depression had on the lives of the students that made
Oppenheimer aware of its devastating impacts.
This broke him in awareness of just how much political and economic events could
affect people's lives.
This is awareness.
It was strengthened as he began to take notice of what was happening in Nazi
Germany.
Having Jewish heritage himselfie looked on with great concern at the rise of
Hitler,
yet it took a woman to transform up at home.
His political concerns into action.
Jean tap block was the graduate students who was studying for a degree in
psychology.
She was also a member of the Communist Party.
Tagalog introduced Oppenheimer to the wells of radical politics.
He joined a number of institutions aligned with the Communists,
so there is no evidence that he actually became a card carrying member of the
Communist Party.
However,
in 1936 his brother frank moved to California and he did join the party.
Oppenheimer.
He fell in love with tatlock and they pursued a tempestuous relationship between
1936 in 1939 with the ends of his contact with tap block his interest in
communism,
it wanes and by the 1940s he had become rather disenchanted with it,
mainly due to hearing reports of what life was really like in the Soviet Union.
Yet despite his later recessions that is flooded with communism was nothing more
than a boyhood fling accusations that he was a Russian sympathizer would dog him
for the rest of his life.
In the wake of his breakup with Tatlock Oppenheimer,
that began a relationship with a woman named Kitty Harrison.
There was however one problem and that's the kitty was married.
She was in fact on her third marriage with her husband to being a British
doctor.
She soon divorced the doctor with Oppenheimer up becoming a fourth husband on
November the first 1914
the bombing of Pearl Harbor on December the seventh 1941 changed the lives of
senior physicists in the United States profoundly overnight.
Their theoretical research,
it was being called upon to help win the war.
The first challenge presented to the physicists was to develop a radar system.
The country's top physicists.
They gathered at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology,
his radiation laboratory,
ready to throw themselves into what they thought would be the great work that
would win the war.
Then in September of 1942 work began on a program that proved to be far more
impactful than the radar project,
and that was of course the development of a nuclear bomb.
In 1939 three German physicists discovered nuclear fission,
which enabled a massive amounts of energy to be released when neutron struck or
uranium nucleus among the first to recognize the massive destructive potential
of this technology.
If it can be harnessed into the form of a bomb where two Hungarian scientists,
they made it their mission to warm the presidents of the United States that he
needed to develop such a bond before the Germans did.
Yup.
These minus scientists could not get anyone to listen to them.
It was only when they secured the support of the world famous scientist Albert
Einstein,
that they were able to get President Roosevelt's attention.
Okay.
As a direct result of a Letteri received from Einstein,
Roosevelt created the advisory committee on uranium.
The committee began to stockpile uranium but didn't move fast enough for
Roosevelts.
It was soon dissolved and replaced with the National Research Defense Council.
The NRDC.
The council was put in the hands of the army with Brigadier General Leslie
Groves having oversight.
The project was given an innocuous name as to not give away its purpose.
Grove's called it the Manhattan project.
Since 1932 Oppenheimer had been doing his own private research into nuclear
physics.
He desperately wanted to get involved in the project in any way that would
advance America's security.
In 1941 he was invited to a top secret meeting of scientists to brainstorm how
to build a nuclear bomb.
He was put in charge of the physics group who were given the task of actually
designing said bomb.
By July of 1943 he had officially joins the Manhattan project,
the Manhattan project.
It was not based in one single location.
Rather there were a number of laboratories located around the country.
Each tackling a specific aspect of the project.
The biggest challenge was the creation of the bomb itself and this task was to
be overseen by often high.
The base of the operation was Los Alamos,
so deserted area or in the north central part of New Mexico.
Dislocation,
which was selected by Oppenheimer himself,
was to be his home for the next three years and older boy's school was renovated
to serve as a base camp with a number of barracks being moved into service homes
for the physicists who would work on the project with the facility ready.
Oppenheimer traveled the country in search of the best scientific minds to help
him build the bond.
In addition to former students eat cold on top physicists.
So number of him,
what Exxon's or Nazi Germany,
if he was concerned that he wouldn't find the people that you need it.
He needed to have been here originally estimated that he would need 30 people,
but scientists from all over the country were energized by the opportunity and
by the end of the war,
they were more than 6,000 people living at Los Alamos.
This is only the primitive living conditions and the oppressive desert.
He's the scientists,
relish that time at Los Alamos.
Many of them have their families with them and spend that time off hiking and
skiing.
We'll leave at the southwest.
While they weren't keen on was the seemingly over the top secrecy imposed by the
military who are ever present.
Every scientist was under constant surveillance and none more so than
Oppenheimer himself.
During his time in Los Alamos,
the government tapped his phone,
opened his mail,
and had men follow him everywhere as overseer of the project.
Oppenheimer perhaps have not only contend with the invasion of his own privacy,
but to mediate between the often feisty scientists in the military.
He constantly reminded the physicists do keep the big picture in mind.
They were involved in a once in a lifetime struggle for the very salvation of
mankind.
By February of 1945 that brains at Los Alamos said,
come up with two designs for the atomic bomb.
They were code named little boy and fat man.
Little boy was a uranium based upon while fat man use plutonium.
The scientists were so confident in the design of little boy that they deemed it
unnecessary to test,
but fat man,
he required testing popping.
I'm a designer to test fat man near Alamogordo New Mexico.
It was a 60 mile stretch of desolate landscape from north to south and 40 miles
east to west to carry out the explosion safely.
They had to ensure that the wind was traveling in the right direction.
If it wasn't radioactive dust and debris,
you could travel over residential areas,
bands,
or wait for what seemed like forever just to get the right conditions.
During this time,
Oppenheimer was wound up with stress that things could go wrong and that they
would unleash destruction on the citizens of New Mexico.
Finally,
the conditions were right.
The explosion took place on July the 16th 1945 the resulting flash was visible
from three states.
The mushroom boundaries,
38,000 feet into the air.
Well,
the crater that was blown into the ground was half a mile wide.
The other scientists scattered at the site,
cheered enthusiastically and the wave of the explosion,
but not Oppenheimer.
He found the situation.
Apps do quote from the Hindu text,
the Bhagavad Gita.
No,
I am to come to a destroyer of worlds.
The decision to make use of the bombs was now in the hands of President Harry s
Truman.
Often much soul searching.
He decided to use it on the Japanese in order to force them to surrender.
On August the sixth 1945 the beat 29 bomber in no to gay dropped little by over
the city of Hiroshima.
90% of the buildings were instantly destroyed along with 66,000 people.
However,
the immediate Japanese surrender was not forthcoming.
On August the ninth Fatboy was dropped on the city of Nagasaki.
You're causing 40 2005 the deaths,
the double whammy,
it was too much.
On August the 14th 1945 Emperor Hirohito announced the Japanese surrender when
he first heard that the bombs had brought about the desired effect.
Oppenheimer rejoiced along with the rest of the nation on laser reflection.
However,
he took in the realization of just what he had unleashed upon the world.
On October the 16th 1945 Oppenheimer relinquished his physician at Los Alamos.
He returned to Caltech before taking up a position as director of the Institute
of Advanced Study at Princeton University.
But it's after three years of excitement,
power,
and and cutting edge research.
He founds the university life whole rather mundane with information about the
Manhattan project now in the public domain,
Oppenheimer became a household figure with his face appearing on the cover of
Time magazine.
He now used his position of prominence do lecture around the country on what he
felt the United States should do with that new found nuclear technology.
From his unique perspective,
he appreciated the technological achievement as well as the killing potential
that did it unleashed in our felt a responsibility to ensure that its future use
was for good and not evil.
He advocated for international sanctions on nuclear power,
but all to no avail.
At the same time,
he appreciated that having nuclear power was a huge advantage to the American
defense program,
so rather than trying to stop it,
he works on how to keep it from going out of control.
Now,
in the postwar years,
a new enemy of the United States emerged.
The Soviet Union,
a Cold War ensued leading to an arms race between what we're now the two weld
superpowers.
The Americans.
Of course,
they had the nuclear advanced age,
but all of that changed in September of 1949 when the Soviet set off a nuclear
explosion of their own,
the Americans were taken off guard having believed that the Russians were well
behind them.
The U S government suspected that spies Mr shed vital information with the
Soviets,
often the game under immediate suspicion thanks to his form,
a connection with the communist party.
Meanwhile,
the Americans rush defines a response to the Russian bomb.
Discussions were held about a new type of bomb,
one that was a thousand times more destructive than those that had been dropped
over Japan.
It was a bomb that was going to be powered by hydrogen,
all the nine that was opposed to the hydrogen bomb fearing that it would become
a weapon of genocide,
but president dream and decided to go ahead anyway,
and then the hydrogen bomb code named Mike was exploded in 1952 in November of
1953 the FBI received a letter from a former government official alleging that
Oppenheimer was a Soviet spy.
It was enough to bring the full power of the Mccarthy Communist witch hunts down
upon him Oppenheim the security clearance.
It was immediate be revoked or three men investigation was then undertaken.
As it progressed,
it became obvious that he was really being investigated for his opposition to
the hydrogen bomb project rather than his supposed ties to the Soviets.
The resulting report permanently shut up and Oppenheimer out of any involvement
in government affairs due to what it termed the proof of fundamental defects in
his character,
following the humiliation of his ouster from the government's Oppenheimer
returns of the Institute for Advanced Study in 1963 with the McCarthy red scare.
Long in the past,
the government offered an olive branch to Oppenheimer by awarding him the Enrico
Fermi Award for excellence and nuclear research.
Still,
he never fully recovered from the humiliation of the 1950s four years later on
February the 18th 1967 he died of throat cancer.
He was 62 years old,
so I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Also don't forget to check our brilliant,
you'll find a link in the description below.
Subscribe to this channel for brand new videos several times a week,
and as always,
thank you for watching.